I just read an email that you said about genetics protein and cancer.
I have my genetics done with you and I'm wondering how I can find out if I should be eating
protein or not. I do have the MAT gene defect and the on and was told to be out of low
methionic diet or the PDH gene defect and be on a low carb diet. So if you want to schedule
a time with me to chat about your genetics, again, if you can't find the genetic readout,
now this person did a genetic workout with us, you know, this person started with us a long time ago.
So I'm pretty sure we worked doing the same thing that we're doing now as far as now we give a
we give you the whole report, which now is like 250 pages. And since that's so hard to digest,
we give a genetic summary report, which we have printed out and we highlight the genes that
we think are the ones of concern. And that is about, I don't know, 15 to 18 pages. And then you really
only have to look at the highlighted genes, which might be only five or six genes that are really
a concern. And now we also give a genetic action step report that is like, okay, really that's the
only thing you really need to look at unless you want to dig in a little bit deeper with the summary
report or if you want to totally geek out on the full one and then follow that along with
going to the reader genes course and watch all the videos that Anne and I have created on the
genetics through the reader genes course. So, but if you just want to know, hey, I just want to know
if I have this gene defect, but I can't figure it out. Look at that, my big report, then call and
schedule a time to go over with me, just try to have your questions organized because
it could be a lot of meat to go through and I don't know what time you'll be able to spend on that.